all right
um okay let's start uh welcome to the
ddps seminar everyone before we
introduce our invited speaker let's go
over some rules and Logistics first of
all please mute yourself during the talk
unless you have questions if you have
questions you are welcome to unmute and
ask otherwise please use chat room to
post your questions so that we can
address them in Q a session at the end
second today's ddps seminar is open to
external audiences therefore no class by
this question is allowed so please watch
out finally The Talk today will be
recorded and uploaded in our YouTube
channel that's about it and now let me
introduce our speaker today it is an
honor to host amea Jack tap who is an
assistant research professor of Applied
Mathematics at Brown University it will
received a PhD and master degrees both
in Aero Space Engineering from the
Indian Institute of science
he then joined in the Tata Institute of
fundamental Research Center for Applied
Mathematics and in India as a
postdoctoral research fellow later he
moved to Brown University to pursue his
postdoctoral research in the division of
Applied Mathematics due to his
interdisciplinary background in
mechanical aerospace engineering Applied
Mathematics and computation a key focus
of his research work is to develop data
and physics-driven scientific machine
learning algorithms applicable to a wide
range of problems in computational
physics his expertise lies in the field
of scientific machine learning deep
learning
data-driven and physics driven and deep
learning techniques with the
multifidality data uncertainty
quantification propagation and
multi-scale and multi-physic simulations
and computational Continuum mechanics
and spectral vinyl element methods and
we know DG schemes domain decomposition
techniques
etc etc he is also interested in the
development of Novel artificial neural
network architecture on which give
faster comparisons today amea will talk
about scientific machine learning
through the lens of physics informed
neural networks please enjoy and expect
a wonderful talk now without further Ado
let me pass the button to Amia by asking
one random question as usual today's
random question is where is your
favorite place in the world
uh I guess my hometown on your hometown
um somewhere in India right yes yes
which haven't I haven't visited since
almost four years now
yes
so thanks thanks for the wonderful
introduction and
today I'm going to present my recent
work and some past work also so the
title of my talk is scientific machine
learning through the lens of pins so I'm
sure uh you must have already heard uh
pins before and maybe some of you are
already working on it so I know young
young so he's doing so I I saw his paper
on Rome pin plus you know for faster
room methods so uh with that let's see
an overview
okay yeah so uh first we will uh quickly
discuss the physics and form neural
network or in short pin method uh we
will also see some performance
Improvement techniques and we will uh
see some of the application scientific
applications of pins where we can apply
I'll also discuss uh some domain
decomposition based extensions of pin uh
namely conservative pin or C pin which
is tailored towards conservation laws
and more General extended pins or X pins
which is the generalized space-time
domain decomposition version and lastly
we will see the recent extension of pins
which is a unified scalable framework
for causal strategies with time domain
decompositions okay so traditional
approaches like finite element method of
finite different method etc etc for
scientific computation underground
remarkable progress but they still
operate under very stringent conditions
so basically they need uh they require
an underlying physical law the precise
knowledge of underlying physical law
also the boundary condition uh and
initial conditions and they often uh
require time consuming workflows such as
mesh generation and the long time
simulation so on the top of this
limitation the real simulation of real
observation data for ill pose inverse
problem uh can be very costly so
basically here you are actually either
discovering the missing physics or you
are calibrating the free parameters in
the model so I'm talking about uh in
this region where we have some data
available and at the same time uh we
also know the uh some some Physics so
basically it's an ill post inverse
problems so on the top of that the data
could be dirty dinky Dynamic and
deceptive okay so uh under this
circumstances uh the traditional method
uh they actually uh they suffer
basically it's not uh sometimes it's
difficult or even impossible to solve
such problem with the traditional method
so in this case physics inform machine
learning can actually help a lot and it
can actually use to solve these problems
so uh just a quick literature survey so
physics informed neural net machine
learning is not new it actually started
uh proposed first by lagaris back in
early uh late 90s and early 2000s okay
uh where he actually used neural network
to solve pde later on uh ORD others
propose a physician for machine learning
for uh basically homogeneous uh uh
problem uh and then uh Cindy framework
by Brunton uh for the dictionary
learning of the dynamical system and
later physics guided neural network uh
at the same year pin also came the first
archive paper
uh later uh Wang also used physics
inform machine learning for turbulence
modeling and the officially pin was
published in JCP in 2019 and there are
so many methods uh similar to this like
physics constraint physics encoded
physics
guided and so on so in this talk
basically we are going to focus on pins
so what is Prince so basically it's uh
it defines a paradigm that is Bridges
the physical model with the
observational data so basically we have
this schematic representation of pins so
on the left hand side you have a typical
feed forward neural network uh whose
inputs are the X and Y which are the
independent variables of the pde and uh
the output is the dependent variable U
the field variable so the field value
variable not only satisfies the data the
target data but also satisfies the
physics part the the pde part basically
the governing equations uh using the
automatic differentiation so so you can
see the loss function which consists of
first term which is the measurement loss
it's a data uh mismatch term and the
second term is the PD residual basically
we are trying to minimize the PD
residual so uh this way we can actually
recast the original PD problem into an
equivalent optimization problem so
minimization of this loss function will
actually drive the solution uh actually
you will get the solution of the PD
okay so basically uh pin aims to learn
this surrogate
uh Theta tilde Theta tilde is the uh
parameters uh in the network okay for
predicting the solution of of the given
3D so by minimizing this loss functions
okay so a pin can use uh to solve both
forward problem and specifically uh it
has an advantage of solving the lpos
inverse problem okay let's see one
pedagogical example so it's a simple
viscous Wendy viscous Burger equation
it's given here uh and my initial
condition is a simple sine wave and my
boundary conditions are zero so these
are the uh hyper parameter and parameter
which I am using data points are 150
which are randomly chosen residual
points where we are evaluating the PDR
8000 activation function hyperbolic
tangent learning rate and so on so
okay here is the uh pectoral
representation so this is the XT uh
domains uh computational domain and you
can see the data points 150 uh given by
this Blue Cross okay and here we compare
the uh exact uh solution with the
prediction basically and in this case
the L2 error uh after uh five just five
thousand iteration is in the range of
minus two uh so here we use Simple uh uh
atom first order atom Optimizer followed
by the second order lvf GS Optimizer
here so this way we can solve the
forward problems
so uh okay before moving to some other
application let's let's discuss some of
the performance Improvement technique
which is the Adaptive activation
functions so this is the uh very basic
question how to choose activation
functions uh and uh it is well known
that uh it's it's there's no rule of
thumb it all depends on problem which uh
problem at hand basically so there are
many open issues while training neural
network like Vanishing and exploding
gradients and the plateau phenomena
uh however empirical observation
actually shows that a well-chosen
activation function can help gradient
descent uh to not only converge fast but
also to generalize well and some of the
desired features of activation function
is non-linearity continuously
differentiable and the range uh well of
course as I said there is no rule of
thumb for choosing the optimal
activation function so this actually the
motivation for to use the Adaptive
activation functions so here we propose
the uh adaptive activation function it's
a global adapter activation function so
fee is my activation function and
calligraphic n z is the input to the
activation function which is coming from
the hidden layer so instead of just this
structure we are actually introducing
the additional parameter n and a where a
n is the predefined positive scaling
factor and a is my tunable parameter so
during initialization we are
initializing n is equal to one basically
here uh so that we can always start with
the actual uh fixed activation function
okay and once we start the optimization
process we are training uh a also which
is a tunable parameter along with the
other parameters of the network so you
can see that uh these are the different
activation functions sigmoor tan H relu
and leaky relu and it actually gives
different values for this uh a a
different a different structure with
with different a values okay so uh this
has already been implemented in the
nvidia's modulus software previously
known as simnet uh we'll see some
examples uh we can also Define instead
of a global parameter n a we can
actually Define these parameters a
locally like layer wise so for all K
layer also for neuron voice okay so that
actually also improves the performance
of the neural network as we will see
later with some examples
okay so this is the theorem we proved uh
this is uh if if you use the most basic
form of the Granite gradient descent
optimization and and you you satisfy at
least one of the following conditions
like constant learning rate diminishing
learning rate and adaptive learning rate
then uh you can actually avoid the
sub-optimal critical points so I'm not
going to prove this but you can see the
proof here it's very simple uh it's a
quite strong uh statement uh but but you
can prove it for very uh basic uh
optimization scheme not for Adam and we
have not rooted for Adam and lpfgs but
for most basic uh gradient descent
method
okay we also propose a generalized
framework for uh activation function
adaptive activation functions so it's
it's Chronicle neural network so instead
of a single activation function fee we
have a series of activation function
from V1 to V K uh
and a particular case of this chronic or
neural network is the Rowdy activation
functions uh where in this case my V1 is
any standard activation function you
choose anything like tanh or in a radio
or anything and the remaining uh fee k
equal to 2 to capital K are chosen uh
these are all sinusoidal basically so
here it's it's like you are
superimposing these uh sinusoidal
sinusoidal noise on the top of the base
activation functions V1 this is very
helpful uh because it can actually
overcome the spectral bias problem
okay let's see some examples so some a
simple uh function approximation example
is this one uh here we use the global
activation Global adaptive activation
function so you can see on the left hand
side it's a fixed on the right hand side
it's Global identity activation function
and you can see the uh prediction after
thousand eight thousand and twenty two
thousand iterations so you can see that
uh the fixed activation function
actually stuck in the local Minima uh
even after 22 000 iteration it cannot uh
you know capture this simple uh function
but on the other hand uh the the global
adaptive activation can easily capture
it you can see this loss function here
for Global it's green curve dashed lines
and uh the fixed is the red curve you
can see that it's stuck in the global
Minima but uh
the globally adaptive activation
function actually converges much faster
and you can see the variation of n a we
initialize n a with one initially and
now as the n a uh a value changes you
can see the loss function is also
converging faster and it actually
optimizes uh it actually saturates at
around 4.5 value
let's see the uh another example so it's
uh it this is now a pin we are solving
2D helmhole's equation basically uh
okay it's it's a high frequency wave uh
you can see that the this is the uh
assumed uh form of the solution and you
can see that here uh blue curve is the
fixed activation function uh green curve
is the uh locally adaptive activation
function and the red curve is the Rowdy
function which we discussed at the end
and among all Rowdy performs best so
rowdy net five means we use K is equal
to five Phi terms uh of course Rowdy is
expensive because we are adding multiple
activation function but then there are
different ways to reduce the cost uh
like transfer Landing which uh already
discussed in the original paper
uh you can also see the relative error
on the right hand side uh in this case
Rowdy is actually you know converging
much faster compared to fixed and the uh
locally adaptive activation functions so
recently we also uh you know put this
survey paper which was uh accepted in
jml MC Journal uh where we compare more
than uh around we discussed more than
180 activation functions and compare uh
using the uh this tensorflow pie torch
and Jacks and
uh we also compare both fixed adaptive
and other other types of activation
function so let's see some scientific
applications here
so first one is high speed flow so
that's basically my PhD uh topic I I
worked on uh
algorithm development for high speed
compressible flows so here uh in this
case uh this is basically a semi-inverse
problem uh the aim is to solve the uh I
mean infer the equation of State
basically the gas constant gamma using
only schlier in data as well as the
pressure data and Inlet condition so you
can see this X Y domain here so this is
a steady state problem so we have an
oblique shock wave which is actually
coming from the left bottom corner okay
and it is an inclined shock wave so uh
there are two cases in first case we
just chose the uh training data point
randomly which is the left hand side
case and on the right hand side I chose
training data uh which is actually where
I'm coalesing more points along the
shock okay in this case it's an inverse
problem from the schillerin data I know
where is the high high gradient
available and and I can actually take
more points in that region and you can
see the results uh at in in the table
below so the true value of gamma is 1.4
that's for air and this is the gamma
with clean data there is no noise the
random value converge value and the
clustered value so cluster value is
obviously it's much accurate than random
because a slight change in the
orientation of the shock can actually
give you completely different gamma
value with fixed initial conditions and
with uh increase in noise you can also
see uh with one person and two percent
noise I'm getting uh the clustered uh
you know data points giving much better
results compared to the randomly chosen
points
uh here is another example where we are
actually quantifying the material
properties uh in particular we are
actually uh quantifying the uh
polychrista nickel material uh in this
case uh we have only uh the displacement
data uh and the aim is to infer the
compliance coefficients of the material
so in this case we uh we we have the uh
X1 displacement data which is available
uh from the experiments and sorry X2
displacement data and X1 and X3
displacement data we actually uh got it
from the uh fem uh solver
so here is the comparison of the
displacement data uh actual versus spin
on these four locations you can see that
they are actually matching pretty well
in this case and for single Crystal
nickel the speed of second Shear wave is
actually 2.97 uh millimeter per
microsecond and these are the plots
which actually shows the uh space
dependent second Shear wave the left
hand side plot which is actually we are
plotting on X1 X3 plane and you can see
that the range is from 2.95 to 3 uh
which actually confirms the uh presence
of the poly crystalline nickel material
so although we couldn't capture the
crystal boundary clearly but we actually
at least confirm that it's a poly
crystalline nickel material and on the
right hand side it's a c44 spatial
variation
so this way actually pin can be also
helpful in quantifying the material uh
uh one more example where we solve the
inverse water wave problem uh basically
uh
in this case the aim is to infer the
velocity field and the corresponding
forces on the wall using only water
column height so the governing equations
Are cereal green magnetic equations
basically and this is the first case so
you can see that this is again an x and
t plane 1D example and ETA is my water
column height and you can see these I'm
not sure it's very small but these are
the black dot lines you can see that
these are 12 gauges which we placed
along the x axis and it gives a Time
series data so that's the only data we
have
in this case 12 gauges on the right hand
side we had 20 gauges and you can see
the predicted velocity at the bottom for
12 gauges and 20 gauges respectively and
that's the point wise error we are
plotting 0.0 error in the water column
height uh also because we don't have all
the information of the ETA we are just
using some uh you know finite set of
values here uh second example in this
case is the uh solitary wave reflection
so you can see the wave which is
actually hitting this column
and then passing
so we use the low Fidelity gauges uh uh
given by the black dots and the High
Fidelity gauges so low Fidelity around
1200 and High Fidelity 50 points
and then we use multi-fidelity pins so
basically the aim here is to map the low
Fidelity data on on High Fidelity gauges
basically and then use those High
Fidelity data you feed those High
Fidelity data to the pin Network for for
the training so that's basically the
correlation between reference and the
predicted
High Fidelity data low and high fidelity
data and that's that's the uh we also
computed along with the velocity we also
computed forces which are acting on the
wall so okay you can see there's this
this is the wall small rectangular
portion I just take upper half portion
here so uh the left hand side is wall
one the top one is wall two and the
bottom in the right hand side is the uh
wall three and you can see the forces uh
on on these three walls uh the reference
solution and the multi-fidelity pin
solution and they're matching pretty
well so that's that's the point wise
error
[Music]
okay so uh let's let's discuss some of
the limitations of pins
so the first one is the due to high
dimensional non-convex optimization
problem the accuracy of the method
suffers so it actually uh the best
accuracy what we get is around -4 minus
five
are now uh with with Jags it is uh
better than that I mean I I can even get
my minus five plus accuracy but it's
again it's not comparable with the
spectral accuracy uh and the second
limitation is the large training time
because specifically for the forward
problem because ping is not yet uh
it is not a competent with the
traditional numerical method uh when the
forward problem is the concern so aim is
to tackle the uh large training time
here uh so let's see uh some of the
classical approaches so first one is the
data parallel approach so here we have
the data we are actually splitting the
data into a number of chunks which is
exactly equal to the number of processor
and we initiate same neural network okay
with with this data set
and then we use distributed Optimizer uh
which average out the gradient loss on
uh on all route processor through
already operation and then we average uh
average gradient of the loss function uh
okay and to update the weights of the
network so that that's one way data
parallel another one is model parallel
approach so here we are splitting the
data into uh small batches okay and
during forward pass uh once uh well in
this case all the hidden layer L1 L2
actually uh are distributed to the
processor so now we have a different
processor for different layer again my
neural network is same so during forward
pass as layer 1 L1 process batch one B1
okay it actually passes to L2 and then
it starts processing B2 and that's how
they actually finishes the forward plus
and once L4 finishes working on B4 the
backward pass kicks off and it finishes
the uh you know Epoch with the pipeline
approach and then they update the
parameters of the network so in both
cases you can see that there is a single
neural network is used so our approach
is basically a domain decomposition
based approach
uh it's very simple so we have a domain
you just divide that domain into a
number of subdomain and instead of
single pin you deploy different pins in
each subdomain and then you need an
additional interface condition along
with the previous to stitch these
subdomains together and additionally you
also get the interface loss function
loss term along with the data mismatch
and the PD residue term okay so what's
the advantage uh of course it has
parallelization capacity uh and then
okay so this is also there for data and
the model parallel approach that's why
actually I uh just put it in the red
color and there these three points in
blue
these are the additional advantage of
domain decomposition based pins which
are not there with the model and data
parallel approach so it has a local
representation capacity we can actually
deploy a powerfully locally powerful
neural network
uh if we are solving an inverse problem
and you know the some some ID you have
some prior knowledge about the
complexity of the solution second you
can efficiently hyper uh adjust all the
hyper parameters of the network using
meta learning approaches and third we
have also uh seen the reduction in the
error propagation in the domain
basically because we are uh you know
supplying additional interface condition
uh in the uh in inside the domain okay
so first domain decomposition method is
conservative pin or C pin
so basically in this case the interface
conditions uh first one is the flux
continuity condition so it's it's
similar to finite volume method we are
actually where we are enforcing the flux
continuity condition in the normal
Direction that's why that's dot 10 is
there and uh second condition is the
average solution continuity condition
that's the U average so here is the idea
so if you have a solution which is
smooth so the average value given by the
two networks so in this case you have
subdomain one pin Network one and on the
other side you have sub domain two pin 2
and this is the interface so when the
solution is smooth the average value
actually uh actually uh the average
continuity condition boils down to
solution continuity condition so that's
the average Point here but when the
solution is discontinuous on the
interface which is a possibility when
you are solving a hyperbolic
conservation loss which admit
discontinuous solution then actually we
are forcing this value at the interface
that means we are actually capturing
these uh shock waves with single point
basically at least theoretically okay
let's see some examples uh so this is a
simple viscous budget that we have seen
earlier
so here we are decomposing the domain
into four parts so you can see along x
axis these three white lines so uh
domain one two three and four from top
to bottom and these are the uh
parameters we used uh in the subdomains
and actually that's the point wise error
shows and we also uh just plotted the
relative L2 error without average term
that means just enforcing the flux
continuity condition and with average
term along with the flux continuity
condition so you can see that with
average term the red curve the relative
L2 error decreases much faster compared
to the without average uh continuity
condition term
excuse me
okay uh let's see one more example
it's a lead driven cavity encompressible
now stock example
uh basically we have 12 sub domains here
sorry we had 12 sub domains here and
these are the hyper parameters of the uh
you know each Network deployed in these
subdomains uh
that's the comparison of the Velocity
field u and v with the gear uh
uh gear data I mean data given by gear
uh and they are actually matching pretty
well so we will use this example for for
parallelization later on let's see some
inverse example inverse viscous Burgers
again
it's a Burgess equation I'm just giving
you simple example just to show that uh
how how easily we can apply uh okay in
this case we have a data given I mean
obtained by from the viscous Burgess
equation and instead of uh you know uh
you know we are actually using instead
of using the exact equation uh with with
the uh you know parameters unknown
parameters we are actually supplying
additional terms and our aim is to find
out these parameters beta Nu and Alpha
so basically we are unsteady term
non-linear convection linear convection
viscous term and the uh
uh third order
ah term dispersuit term basically and
with viscous Burgess equation we know
that uh my Beta should be zero because
the flow is from basically left to right
uh my new should have some value a
positive value because it's viscous
equation and my Alpha should be zero
okay so uh because it's it's not
dispersing so we initialize uh these
again the same problem uh what we
consider the forward problem last time
with four sub domain we initialize Alpha
Beta And Nu differently in these
subdomains and you can see that once the
optimization optimization procedure
starts they are actually going towards
the exact value okay so you can it's
interestingly you can see that uh new
value it actually overshoots the exact
uh solution because Alpha and beta they
were still converging the moment they
converge to their original exact value
which are 0 it actually start it done
converging towards its original value so
these are the uh comparison C pin
comparison which are pretty accurate
okay so what what next uh so basically
uh you know it would be uh uh really
Advantage if we use the domain
decomposition strategy for every PD and
not necessarily for conservation law
moreover uh if you have domain
decomposition in space and time that
would be uh really helpful for many uh
large scale problem so the yes we can do
it uh the answer is X pin here we can
actually
uh employ this so let's see the
interface condition so the first
interface condition is same as C pin its
average solution continuity condition
and the second interface condition is
the residual continuity condition so
basically we are saying that my residues
are same along the interface so this
actually will help you to decompose The
Domain in space and time arbitrary day
so we don't have to worry about D shape
and you know even if even if it is a
moving domain it will be really helpful
so it because you know there there is
you know uh just like flux continuity
condition we are not finding any normals
here or nothing so it just uh residual
continuity condition and plus you can
add additional continuity condition if
you have any like uh you know integral
constraint higher order uh derivative
requirements and so on so advantage over
cpin we can extend it to any
differential equation uh as I said uh we
can actually decompose in space and time
and implementation wise the interface
conditions are simple because we don't
have to find out you know normal
Direction which would be really
complicated in terms of moving interface
in high dimensional you know problems
okay here is the comparison uh of Pin C
pin and X pin special domain uh yes C
pin can do X pin can do both CP next pin
has parallelization capacity uh local
representation capacity and efficiently
adjust all the hyper parameter C pin can
be actually applicable for only
conservation laws but x-min can be used
for any differential equation interface
conditions are complex in C pin uh but
uh it's a simple index pin moreover
explain has additional spatial temporal
domain decomposition
capability so let's see again same
viscous budget and now we are
decomposing domain into a dolphin shape
uh domain two and the outside blue c is
the domain one basically and you can see
the uh hyper parameters here and this is
the predicted solution versus exact
solution and and related L2 error after
15 000 iteration is uh this much
so the whole point is to show that we
can actually decompose in such a weird
way in space and time and we can easily
solve this kind of problems with X-Men
uh one more example 2D compressible
Euler equations so we have a oblique
shock reflection test case uh the shock
actually created at the top left corner
it actually then hits the bottom wall
and the reflected back so in this case
you can see a peanut shaped domain uh
domain one and outside domain two so I
chose this because eventually the shock
will uh hit the these it will pass
through these two sub domains and
reflect it
and here is the uh prediction a pressure
density and velocity in X and Y
Direction and this is the comparison
with the exact solution at location Y is
equal to 0.5 so this is pretty much
accurate uh results uh we can see the
smearing of the shock but of course if
we use more points uh or active learning
strategy or something like that then we
can actually get much better results
we have also implemented a cpin explain
uh parallelly
so I'll just quickly show you some of
the results uh
okay this is the computation versus
communication time
on GPU so basically that's the right
hand side plot is for the C pin uh for
the C pin you can see that computation
time in Pinker color and the
sorry a blue color and the communication
time in pink uh in X pin on the right
hand side the communication time is more
that's obvious because
we are enforcing the residual continuity
condition we are actually enforcing the
whole pde to be continuous along the
interface condition which needs more uh
communication compared to just enforcing
the flux continuity condition in C pin
this is the weak scaling we have done uh
and these These are the uh uh
sample per second plots on number of
gpus we use till 24 gpus for this is for
xpin and this is for C pin uh obviously
for xpn sample per second is less
compared to cpin
uh because of obvious reason uh but it
matches well uh with with the
theoretical curve
and and that that's the strong scaling
basically so that's the speed up uh and
the efficiency you can see that for cpin
it's almost linear uh
uh slightly less uh and for X pin it is
again uh lesser than uh C pin speed up
uh because again uh the communication
and computation time is more for explain
compared to C pin in terms of efficiency
uh C pin almost hit 80 percent and the
x-pin hits uh 70 basically
if you have any question you can you can
ask me uh you don't have to wait till
till end
anyone wants to ask question uh by
unmuting yourself
I know Yosef has putting the questions
in the chat
okay okay maybe I can
I get yourself to you yeah yourself do
you owner
I have a question yes because uh now you
have the the composition of the domain
but um
in case you have for example a shape
that is not that is discontinuous from
uh from your other domains okay is it
possible to do experience in that case
what what do we mean by decompose uh
like if you have like cylinder or
something like and you want to do
aerodynamics or fluid
so it yes you can you can still do it
right uh so the domain is still at it's
a single domain right
so it's it's uh it's not Simplex it it's
uh uh you mean to say domain with some
some voids or holes yes yes yeah you can
still you can still use these domain
decomposition based methods
thank you
thank you very much a very interesting
presentation
um The Domain decomposition is that a
manual process or is there a way to
automate it based on the geometry
characteristics of whatever you're
analyzing yes so uh I'll show you in my
uh some future slides uh you can
automate that process uh we just
published that paper in Siam
based on the uh some some based on some
bounds so but of course uh
it's it's not that easy because uh uh if
it is an inverse problem then of course
it's easy you can automate this process
or uh we are also working on some moving
uh domains basically where the
interfaces are moving uh because you
know with time the complexity can move
in certain parts of the region so uh in
order to track that compact complexity
uh we need the moving interface you know
subdomains so in that case also you can
also do that but we are still working on
those those ideas thank you
okay I'm here you can go on okay okay
uh so uh this is the part we we recently
worked on where we propose a unified
scalable framework for causal uh
sweeping strategy
for pins and uh with their temporal
decomposition domain decomposition so uh
some of the limitations of vanilla pin
we can see here uh figure a figure B and
figure C figure a is the simple linear
convection equation uh
figure B is again the same equation but
for uh you know short time 0 to 1 and
figure C is the Allen current equation
so we have seen some of the uh issues uh
with the vanilla pin uh some of the
limitations is zero solution propagation
specifically for the boundary condition
uh case a so you can see that the
boundary is periodic
it satisfies the initial condition and
it also satisfies the periodic boundary
condition even though the solution is
zero it still satisfies the boundary
condition right so that's that's one of
the uh the uh issue we have seen later
we also have seen no information
propagation at all so you can see that
the in this case this is the exact
solution in this case this is exact
solution and this is the exact solution
and these three are predicted Solutions
so the predicted solution there is no
information is propagating at all uh and
third one this is the predicted solution
and you can see that this is basically
an incorrect information propagation so
it converges but actual solution is
different from what you are getting okay
so some of the strategies that has been
proposed uh to overcome these
limitations are time domain
decomposition strategies so here I'll
show you the pictorial representation a
b c and d so a is the Adaptive time
sampling so basically it actually has uh
you're splitting the domain along time
axis okay and you have single Network so
once you train the network subdomain you
just add another subdomain and so on
till you finishes the last uh sub domain
okay so that's the Adaptive time
sampling strategy second one is BC pin
so basically it's a backward
compatibility spin so once you train the
network you can see this red points here
once you train the network you convert
that predicted solution into a data
points so that will be a data point for
the ongoing uh uh I mean ongoing
training in this network shown by the
black lines okay so that's how you
actually March in time and then there
are you know Time marching techniques uh
and the X pin which we have already
discussed so in this case Time marching
is again time splitting and they use
separate networks instead of same
network okay that's that's the uh
difference and we already see next pins
before so so these strategies can
actually uh help in tackling all these
issues which we discussed previously a
moreover it can also title the long time
integration issue on the other hand we
also have causal weights okay so
basically in this case we have single
Network and we are defining a
collocation point mask that moves in
time uh inverse uh exponentially
proportional to the magnitude of the
prior so I'll come to that in more
detail
so uh here I'm trying to classify the uh
causality enforcements method into a
soft hard causality soft causality
combination of both and non-causal uh
with time slab scales so basically these
are the discrete enforcements uh on the
scale of the partition slab and the
sampling rate so here it is the
continuous information or descale of the
collocations uh Point sampling you can
see that these methods are actually
finding uh some space here so it's like
like adaptive time sampling is a soft
cross LED plus time domain decomposition
time matching BC pins and X pins they're
all time scale time domain decomposition
methods and causal weights is not time
domain decomposition because it actually
put more weights for the whole domain
but it can be do for time domain
decomposition too so you can see here
there are some missing methods here we
will we will try to fill this Gap okay
so idea is the first idea is the stack
decomposition so this actually Bridges
the you know sequentially trained Time
marching methods and parallel train
explain so in this case we are training
one subdomain at a time so it is shown
by the yellow uh box the yellow color
and these are the finished uh already
finished trainings uh Zone and here it
will be a future training uh
we are training everything at once
okay so stack decomposition is in
between these two so instead of just
single domain we can actually choose
number of more than one sub domains to
train so that will actually reduce the
training cost okay
second idea is window sweeping so
basically it's a generalization of time
shipping collocation point methods like
adaptive and the causal weight so you
can see that the point weight along
y-axis and the time on x-axis so you
have a hard sorry you have a hard causal
points where you are applying a boundary
condition or initial condition at the
starting okay here weights are more and
then it is actually gradually decreasing
okay so we can we can play with how how
to decrease these causal weights and for
future uh set our weights are very very
low okay so one example here it
basically actually introduces a kernel
variable kernel like uniform linear or
error function so this is the example of
error function here so how these error
functions the weights are moving in time
so you can see that this is the blue
line with boundary condition width these
are hard causal uh the green with the
null set
the weights are very small or zero and
then the gradual increment in the weight
so we are putting more weights uh to
learn the solution for small time and
then we are slowly increasing that it is
actually sweeping that weights in
forwarding time basically okay
keeping this hard causal boundary
conditions and you know null state for
future points will can reduce the
computational cost drastically okay so
we can actually put these now we can see
that we can actually try it we we we
were able to you know fill these gaps uh
with stack domain decomposition we can
actually uh you know enforce both soft
and hard causality in time domain
decomposition and uh also in sampling
scale we can also employ both in a hard
end soft way okay uh
the unified framework is to use both
stack decomposition as well as window
sweeping method together okay on the top
of that we also use transfer learning
and fine tuning so basically what once
we train one sub domain we can actually
use the same weights and the train
weights and buyers as an initializer you
know initialization for the next uh
neural network for for the future uh
subdomain okay
okay so algorithm is very simple so we
just need to choose the choose the stack
decomposition parameters here
like number of you know divisions n in
time d s how much weight how much how
many sub domains you need to train at
once okay and so on and then choose
interface condition whatever the
condition you have rational continuity
or any other continuity conditions like
initial condition or higher order
initial condition if you are solving a
higher order uh PDS and then of course
the time uh transfer learning parameters
you can choose how many numbers you want
to keep fixed and how many uh you know
layers you want to tune it further and
then we choose window stripping
parameter like BC State null State
waiting kernel and kernel hyper
parameters and finally we run the model
okay so let's see the simple uh quote
device kdb case it's a third order uh
dispersive model okay so initial uh
condition is simple uh cost function
with and the boundary condition is
periodic so uh here there are two cases
uh it's just it's short time interval 0
to 1 and the long time integration zero
to five so for short time you can see
that PIN error uh it is almost in the
same order with the sdsd stands for
stack decomposition and WS stands for
window sweeping schemes so we applied it
separately and together so they are more
or less same
uh but when you go for large long time
integration
okay so you can see that the combination
of SD and window sweeping gives much
better results and also in terms of
computational cost it is uh very very
cheap compared to the original vanilla
pin method so uh as I said it can
actually solve the long time integration
problem easily without any issues that
that we discussed before
okay this this is the uh thing uh we we
recently published that's what I said uh
so the first one is uh when do explain
improve and generalization this is the
Siam Pro uh assigned paper uh here we
discuss how to you know uh decompose the
domain uh uh and how to automate the
process to decompose the domain uh and
uh we also published this uh first
comprehensive theoretical analysis of
pinx pin for non-linear PD basically uh
for Navia stock equation uh there's the
error estimates we we propose uh the
idea is very simple uh for uh you can
actually give the uh
the the actual error in the solution in
terms of the training error uh so I
today I'll not discuss this this point
these two methods but hopefully in
future some sometime I like I'll discuss
so uh here is the conclusion so first uh
we presented pins uh we have also seen
some application of pins uh high speed
flows material quantification uh we have
seen performance Improvement technique
like our adaptive activation functions
uh we also discussed some domain
decomposition based strategies like cpin
and X pin uh which has obvious advantage
over you know vanilla pin like
parallelization capacity uh local
representation capacity uh uh also uh
it's computationally very efficient for
you know uh problems like uh High
dimensional problem uh you know or Big
Data basically and we also discuss a
recent work on unified scalable
framework for causal strategies uh with
time domain decomposition that basically
uh you know overcome many limitations of
pin including time uh time long time
integration so uh here I'll stop uh and
I'll happy to answer your questions if
you have any thank you thank you so much
for the wonderful talk I mean yeah
um let's have a q a session
um so it's
open to anyone
well I know yourself you you have asked
during the talk but I I know
you have more questions in the chat
um do you wanna
meet yourself and ask those questions or
it's up to you
yourself are you there
is he here
yes yes sorry no question thank you
thank you all right sounds good okay
anyone
the unmute or raise your hand
well while you're thinking about it okay
so if you go to
very beginning you're talking about the
Cindy as a
um the physics informed but
in my understanding
um Cindy is not physics important
method
it's a it's a physics Discovery method
it's not yes yes yes so basically they
provide the dictionary learning uh for
dynamical system and those dictionaries
are provided by the user it's not it's
not driven by physics okay okay
yeah so it's yeah
yeah I just wanted to point out that all
right
um
any
and in the conclusions you
you are claiming that it's very
efficient for the high dimensional
problems what do you exactly mean by
high dimensional like
High dimensional in 3D like the 2D
or parameter space being high
dimensional uh basically I'm talking
about physical dimensions three
dimensional uh now we are actually
working on a turbulence problem
uh it's 3D turbulence so we have DNS
data and it's a long time integration so
we decompose uh
that that problem uh using X pins and uh
it can actually the aim is to infer the
uh you know the
uh
the material or the fluid flow
properties basically uh the stress
strength relation uh for that flow uh
basically it's tabulous model and we
there is no way you can you can you know
fit that huge amount of DNS data in a
single pin Network okay so uh so maybe
in soon in a couple of weeks we'll put
that paper on archive where we have used
X pins and the results are much
promising so it can actually solve this
kind of uh physical you know higher
dimensional problem uh basically it's
four dimensional including time
uh and uh that that's what I mentioned
that's what I meant bye bye but of
course uh as far as parametric space is
concerned High dimensional parametric
space uh that that's also a good idea to
you know decompose that space and um if
I mean some strategy can can be
developed to you know decompose that
kind of high dimensional space yeah got
it I'm looking forward to that paper
you're gonna share
um soon on the three dimensional the
navigation yeah the the turbulence
problem DNS so you use the data there
you're not only relying on the residual
thumbs um no I mean of course we have
the uh you know physics informed part
but we are also enforcing the DNS data
uh we are enforcing the the the the
equations
uh and uh aim is to you know infer the
all the turbulence parameter in the
model turbulence models basically yeah
okay sounds good
um
one more questions you know
when you say it's improved from
you know previous the method it's you
know with respect to the previous pins I
assume
um not not with the comparison with the
uh traditional numerical method of
pde
yes the uh the last approach you mean to
say uh yeah the for example yes yes one
you're mentioning like the DNS 3D it's
improved
um well this isn't in most problem uh
uh basically the DNS tabulous uh problem
you are talking about inverse problem
okay yes yes so uh I'm actually
comparing with the vanilla pin I'm
basically uh and not not with the
traditional method I see
okay
thank you on the jolton
um you have a question you can omit yeah
thanks to me a very nice presentation I
have to admit I don't know a lot of
details in the pins so this question
might be a little silly um but but in
the beginning you mentioned that the
advantage of pins is that you can deal
with you know dirty noisy data and all
of those things and so I wonder your
your and I know you didn't cover this
but but I wonder your your
um
thoughts on like how bad can it get in
terms of noisy data or missing data or
just faulty data when pins can recover
the structure underneath
so do you have any pointers
uh well uh well in this talk I have not
heard but there are other versions of
pins like multi-fidelity pin uh which
can actually tackle high low Fidelity
data and uh in that paper uh from our
group we have shown that uh it can
actually uh you know uh tackle uh from
say one percent to around five percent
noise in the data uh we assume the
gaussian noise uh and another framework
is the Beijing uh pin framework uh
there actually then you know there are
other ways to quantify uh the uncertain
related uncertainty related to the uh
you know uh you know solution with with
this noisy data set so yeah I mean uh
pin can definitely tackle a noisy data
set but and we have well in the original
paper uh of pins in mazia's paper he has
also shown uh you know uh you know some
inverse problem where they are adding
some noise data around five percent uh
noise uh and then they try to recover
the uh original equations or parameters
in the uh you know model so yeah it can
still tackle I mean of course for large
data uh
it's it's a challenge for pin two uh but
till five five percent it's it's fine
cool thank you
sounds good okay um any other question
guys
well if not let's thank uh our speaker
for the wonderful talk and um the Q a
sessions
thank you thank you yongsu for for the
invitation actually
um
you raise the hands why don't you okay
oh hi um thank you for the talk it was
interesting and um I think I guess I'm
also not expert in the opinion so I
might like
not fully follow your talk but um
I just
my question is
um like I think you mentioned like
when you're getting into like turbulence
you can
you cannot just use the single like
single neural network and so
I guess from based on your experience
like do you have some sort of an idea
like how many set of your network do you
need
okay in in this particular problem that
we are solving we had uh around
1024 snapshots 3D snapshots of the uh
turbulence problem uh and we use
different scenarios so for example uh we
use different gpus
uh one one one one uh around 64 GPU 128
GPU and even 1024 gpus and where we have
shown uh
in in this paper that how how it scales
uh of course with 1024 gpus the results
are much better because you have you
know uh 1024 networks basically uh in
this case
um so so uh
with with increasing number of networks
so you have more uh you know expression
expressibility uh so uh the
approximation will be much better as the
expression power uh for the neural
network increases okay so that that's
that's what we have shown
so hopefully I'll we'll put that paper
soon on archive
I see yeah thank you so much welcome
thank you
um is there any other question
last chance
all right let's thank our speaker thank
you so much Amia uh what a wonderful
talk thank you as I said before um
hopefully after this talk um someone is
going to contact you and then
yeah right
yeah thank you thank you all right
sounds good thank you everyone